je voulais vous dire que j avais pas ce
qu'il manque du matériel
vous promettez de manger une proposition
de lausanne tout à l'heure je leur ai
dit qu'on allait réfléchir comme à tous
les autres fous tu te remets ta jouets
aura une force ses soucis de santé
vous qui êtes un peu dans l'électricité
c'est comme si je n'avais plus de
courant bonjour c'est pour une livraison
merci de la ressource je te présente
devant rester ou cliente
ça fait plus d'un an que t'as pas
d'histoire et à tout un corps et
christian débarqué du temps amoureuse
écoute pas je vais me remettre à jouer
j'avais envie quand je vous ai j'ai un
magasin je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
tout de suite senti que vous lui
plaisait beaucoup écouté non si vous
caler mais écoutez ce que j'ai à vous
dire les très simple ne l'approché plus
jamais
jamais imaginé les choses autrement
jamais pensé à une autre vie au temps
mort on ne me dit rien je suis heureuse
je suis pas sûr que tu sois heureuse
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire je sais
pas
c'est même dire quelque chose mais pas
et si jamais ça marchait pas tous les
deux il lui resterait quoi je t'imagine
tapis avec moi sur ma place
vous voulez que je vous dise vous n'êtes
pas assez forte pour aimer
si vous étiez vous n'auriez pas d'états
d'âme